as always no matter what poll numbers I
give you you need to vote in November
whether the Republican is up 20 or down
20 or a neo-nazi child molester you need
to assume but it's a close race and that
your vote is a necessity with those
disclaimers out there I want to talk
about Wisconsin's gubernatorial race
where the Republican incumbent Governor
Scott Walker could go down okay
Democratic challenger Tony Evers is
running against Scott Walker Walker's
been governor since 2011 he is five
points behind the Democratic challenger
in a new PPP poll now of course normal
caveats number one PPP is a left-leaning
pollster number two they have it 49 to
44 which still leaves 7% undecided or
possible third party both of which can
end up breaking towards the incumbent as
we close in on Election Day but right
now this is the only post primary poll
that we have out of Wisconsin and
putting aside for a second the slight
leftward lean of PPP polls in general
even if the poll is off by five points
plus the margin of error right so
instead of being plus five Tony Evers is
down three that's still huge and that
still means that Scott Walker could go
down in Wisconsin if people actually get
out and vote we've got 11 weeks left
it's insane that we're only 11 seems
like just yesterday Donald Trump was
elected president and we're only 11
weeks from the 2018 midterms and
defeating Scott Walker would be just a
huge win not only for progressives but
also for workers in Wisconsin because
Walker has been this massively anti
worker and sort of a darling of the
right to work crowd and it could
completely change the tone of Wisconsin
for 2024 the presidential election and
you might remember I certainly haven't
forgotten that back during the 2016
presidential election Donald Trump ended
up winning Wisconsin by about 27,000
votes
Hillary's Clinton Hillary Clinton's
presence in Wisconsin was what we're
calling limited or maybe extremely
limited we might say or non-existent or
almost completely non-existent so having
this change in direction
Wisconsin could be huge for what
ultimately happens in the presidential
in 2020 but I want to go back to the
most important part of this even if the
Democrat was really up five right now
that means more Democrats need to vote
because if the Republicans think for a
second that they're down five they will
try to suppress six percentage points
worth of Democratic votes they are doing
it
Russia's interfering we've been told
that many times by our intelligence
agencies in Georgia as we talked about
earlier in the program today they are
trying to close 7 of 9 polling places in
a predominantly black and
democratic-leaning area and every single
person must vote you can volunteer for
Tony Evers information at Tony Evers
dot-com and on a side note one of the I
read a bunch of articles this morning
preparing for this story always say the
Democratic candidate and a Democratic
Party this is a thing that's been around
for decades actually but in the last
five to ten years it's really grown and
I don't often explain it Democrat Party
and the Democrat candidate it's an
epithet that was developed by the right
decades ago and there's a whole
grammatical argument around it which is
well when we talk about the Democratic
Party that implies small d--
democratic-- like it is a party of
democracy rather than a party called
capital D Democratic so the right will
often say it's grammatically correct to
say the Democrat Party it is a way that
the right has figured out to avoid
associating democracy with the
Democratic Party
don't say the Democrat Party don't say
the Democrat the Democrat candidate I'm
not language policing I'm giving you
strategic political advice this is
something that has been of debatable
effectiveness but don't play into it and
I've even found some people on the Left
who start saying the Democrat challenger
don't say it all the ton of the articles
written by right-wing media about this
Scott Walker poll talk about the
Democrat candidate Tony Evers it's the
Democratic candidate yeah I hate this it
leaves such a bad taste in my mouth it's
just poor grammar at the end of the day
and the real the right Graham I don't
think so and and they also use it
because it ends in the word rat so yeah
that makes people you know associate
negative things with
the Democrat Party very ayah that ended
there's even memes about rats it it's
stupid just don't use it and most
importantly whether you live in
Wisconsin whether you live in
Pennsylvania whether you live in
Massachusetts I don't care where you
live although I'd love to hear about
what it's like living there I don't mean
I literally don't care I mean regardless
of where you live or irregardless of
where you live both of which mean the
same thing
you got a vote that's really the point
here you absolutely have to vote